à
chaque petite phrase sa nouvelle
polémique la provocation assumée d'
emmanuel macron très manuelle maquereau
en roue libre emmanuel macron persiste
et signe
[Musique]
on n'était pas y attendais pas trop
hier le face à face était tendu j mc on
vous met pas que l'avion soit bloqué
arrêté de la bleue
trouver la meilleure façon je suis en
train d'accepter ce n'est pas de faire
peur à votre ferme et nous la meilleure
place tout le pays un costard c'est
travail
[Musique]
kwassa kwassa
kwassa
kwassa kwassa que je peux et puis là
mais nous
savions ce soir l'entourage du chef de
l'état reconnaît est une plaisanterie
regrettable et malheureuse se commet
rien ne dit pas autre chose mais comment
rien et les franco-comoriens les
citoyens français viennent et comment
sont blessés indigné par sa part c'est
cette maladresse
[Musique]
la france n'est pas un pays qui se
réforme notre pays ne se réforme pas
parce que nos concitoyens parce que vous
aussi longtemps qu'il est possible de ne
pas faire les réformes indiqué par les
livres ou les procédures on se cabre on
résiste je ne céderai rien
ni aux fainéants ni aux cyniques ni aux
extrêmes
[Musique]
mais certains au lieu 2 le bordel ils
feraient mieux d'aller regarder
parce qu'il y en a qui on les qualifie
manuel macron un allemand dans le texte
mais compréhensible par tous je ne suis
pas arrogant proclame le chef de l'état
à la une du spiegel avec cette précision
je dis et je fais ce que je veux le chef
de l'état déplorant fin certain état
d'esprit qui selon lui règne en france
vis-à-vis de ceux qui réussissent je ne
céderai pas aux tristes réflexe de la
jalousie française parce que cette
jalousie paralyse le pays et c'est cette
phrase là qui provoque aujourd'hui à
gauche comme à droite les plus vives
réactions après avoir expliqué que les
français ne supportait pas les réformes
qu'ils étaient faits niant qu'ils
étaient cynique maintenant on apprend
qu'ils sont envieux et que en réalité ça
serait leur envie qui paralyse le pays
[Musique]
je dirais que c'est une communication
très maîtrisée met une communication qui
est en distance avec les français et
donc il va falloir qu'ils deviennent à
la fois bien sûr homme d'état mais aussi
homme du terroir il pourrait être homme
du terroir il faut beaucoup de proximité
et ça pour l'instant on sent qu'il ya
une absence il ya un manque très claire
de proximité avec les français gare
c'est un lieu où on croise
les gens qui réussissent et les gens qui
ne sont rien
[Musique]
la politicienne regarder on met un
bonnet d'âne dans des minima sociaux les
gens ils sont impôts on n'en sort pas
mais on est pauvres restent pauvres ceux
qui tombent peau et reste pauvre on a un
truc il permet aux gens s'en sortir
[Musique]
marc entendre emmanuel macron un
restaurant parisien sur deux
embaucherait c'est du moins ce que le
président de la république a assuré ce
week end un jeune horticulteur au
chômage franchement hôtels cafés
restaurants
je traverse la rue je vous trouve ils
veulent simplement des gens qui sont
prêts à travailler avec les contraintes
du métier
[Musique]